If I had to guess, which you are kind of making me
do, I would say, well, for one thing, the number of parameters is
infinite. Right? Because if it's some convex polygon, and we're not putting any
bound on the number of sides on that polygon, then to specify it,
you have to give what the points are for each of the vertices
and the, you know, as the number of sides grows, the number of
parameters grows. So it's, it's unbounded. So it could be that the vc
dimensions is going to end up being unbounded but they do seem you know
at the limit they turn into circles and circles ended up being
a vc dimensions of three so maybe, you know, maybe it's three.
>> Maybe. So, so actually you, you, you've really sort of stumbled on
the right answer there, or maybe not so stumbled, on, on to the answer
there. So, in the limit, convex polygons become circles. Right? So
draw a circle for me, okay, now, let's sort of try to do this smartly, so put a
point on the edge of the circle, yeah I like how
you placed that, so pretty clearly you could come up with a
convex polygon that puts that either in or outside of it
right? Because you know, there is only one point, thats pretty easy.
>> Yeah, and the circle is kind of irrelevant.
>> Yeah the circle is kind of irrelevant, but its going to be
part of my little trick. So put another point on the circle somewhere.
And in the same way we've been doing it before with lines,
you know, you can put both of the inside a convex polygon or
outside, you know, you can do all the labels. I think
that's pretty easy to see. Now try three. So, the first thing
I want you to notice Michael, is that if I look at
those three points and I connected them together, what do I get?
>> Oh a triangle!
>> I get a triangle which is by the way, it starts with a C.
>> [LAUGH] A sheep that has the
number of vertices equal to your favorite number.
>> That's right. But it's also a kind
of geometric shape, it starts with an A.
>> It
starts with a
>> It starts with AC?
>> Appaplectic.
>> No it starts with a C. AC, Accenuated. No it starts with the letter C.
>> Oh. Convex.
>> Yes. It's actually convex polygon. Try
putting a fourth point on there. And in
fact put the fifth point. And a sixth
point. Now, here's my question. We've put all
of these points on this circle, right? Now
let's just say it's a unicircle because it's
easy to think about it. So we put all these points on the circle. Do you
think we could shatter this with a convex polygon?
>> To shatter it? Right, to give it all possible labellings. Well,
let me draw the polygon. So each one being in or out.
>> Well, the thing is, the way you've drawn this polygon, all of them are
in. So, if you used this polygon, what would you be labeling those six points?
>> All positive.
>> All positive. What if I didn't want you to label one of
the points positive? Pick one of the points. Any point will do. So if
I don't want that to be in the polygon, what do I have to do?
>> Just push the, the corresponding vertex a little bit inside.
>> Right. And the easiest way to do that would be not to
have a vertex there at all but simply not to connect that point.
>> Oh. It's kind of like a, a rubber band art or
string art if we just kind of pop that one out. [NOISE]
>> Right. So, ant point you'd, of those
six points you don't want to be labeled positive.
Just don't connect in as a part of your polygon.
>> I see. So, for any given pattern or subset, which
is what we need to be able to show, that, you know,
when we're shattering, we need to show that no matter what the
subset is, there's going to be some. Hypothesis that labels it appropriately.
You're saying, well just, you know, label the points as plus and
minus, and connect up the pluses. It's going to leave the minuses
outside because they're going to be on the edge of the circle. And
the pluses are all going to be in the polygon because they
touch the edges of it.
>> Yeah, because they are in fact the vertices. And in this
case you just think of the fact that if there's only two positive
points a line is a very, very simple convex polygon and if
there's only one point, then a point is a very simple convex polygon.
>> So the VC dimension is six!
>> No! So what happens if I had seven points? Could I do it?
>> So the VC dimension is seven!
>> What if I had eight points? Could I do it? It's the same trick.
We can make it eight.
>> So, can we make it nine?
>> No.
>> Yes.
>> So, at what point can we stop?
>> When we run out of tape for the recording.
>> Exactly. So that means that the number of points that we can
capture this way is in fact unbounded. Which means the VC dimension is infinite.
>> Nice example.
>> Now, I do want to point out that
there's a, a teensy tiny little point here that,
that we sort of skipped over, but I can explain in
five seconds, which is we made polygons. We didn't actually argue that
they were convex, but they are convex, because they're all inside
the unit circle, and by construction, every, any polygon whose vertices are
on the unit circle will be convex. So it's just that's
why we needed a circle, that's why we were being clever with
it, but there you go. So we have a polygon that
we can always draw with those the right thing and because its
always subtended by it's circle it will be convex.
So we have actually found a vc dimension that's infinite
[CROSSTALK]. Or a hypothesis class that has a vc dimension.
[CROSSTALK] It has to be infinite, yeah that's what I
said. We have actually found the hypothesis class whose vc
dimention is infinite and we came up with a proof
where y would be that case, and nicely, I think
very nicely connects with the observation you made earlier. That,
somehow, it connects with the number parameters. I think it's kind of
cool. I mean, you, you, end up with a circle, not
having a very good VC dimension, a very high VC dimension,
but convex polygons, which somehow seem not to be as cool
as circles, are in fact, in fact have infinite VC dimension.
Okay so there you go so we've done some practice of
VC dimensions. So you've given me all this VC dimension stuff,
I agree that it's cool Michael, but what does it have to
do with, what we started out this conversation with? How does that
answer my question about the natural log of an infinite hypothesis space?